[Music]
all right let's go out to Richmond
Virginia and talk to an aluminum
baseball bat Easton what's up
Easton hey John what's up good to talk
to you man I am starstuck right now I
don't know about you I'm dude I don't
get to talk to somebody named after
baseball bats very of in Easton so it's
good great to talk to you it's fantastic
what's up man it's an honor thank you
thank you uh so first I want to say um
and this ties into um that you you you
you and your show played a huge role in
uh saving my marriage after infidelity
and and helping my wife and I build it
into something completely new and so
much better um so I really want to thank
you in thank you for that we uh we're
actually coming down to uh to Nashville
in October to come see uh marriage
getaway this this show is turning into a
big uh marriage Retreat commercial
that's that's awesome I'm glad you're
coming dude um think it'll be sold out
by the time this podcast airs but um
dude that's fantastic we can't wait to
see you it's going to be a blast thanks
yeah we're we're we're still very cool
man so what's up man how can I help all
right so the big question I've got for
you today is how do I start loving
myself um and then I've got got some
context if you want as well go for
it uh all right so I Ted it out because
I'm super nervous bring it that's good
so as long as I can remember I I haven't
really liked myself uh for a long time I
hated myself I was I was a fat kid in
school I was awkward I felt like I
couldn't do anything right that kind of
stuff um and I I worked on really
avoiding that and just kind of ignoring
the the voices in my head telling me I
wasn't good enough but when my wife was
unfaithful um it really brought those
voices back to the Forefront and uh
they've they've just been screaming at
me ever since um I've gotten really good
at kind of logic my way out of it that
all right that's probably not true but
it's it's been really hard for me to
really believe that I guess in my heart
and so I'm at a point now where I don't
hate myself I know I'm not terrible but
I cannot fathom loving myself and I I
just don't even know where to start with
that um and that's why I called in today
dude that's
awesome um I think by the time this airs
um it will I will have I've been doing a
ton of media lately so I don't remember
which if I've said this on this show but
I'll go ahead and say it here um and
this is me being as open as I can too
okay
um we did a study a while ago we did a
survey and asked um a lot of our
audience you know what's your favorite
things about the show what do you not
like Etc one of the very top things that
people don't like about this show they
get frustrated with is I'm always
telling people that you're worth be in
love and you have to start any sort of
Lifestyle transformation from a place of
I care about myself enough to go be a
steward of my money my body my
relationships whatever and their Chief
complaint was that I talk to myself so
badly on this show I'm always making
jokes about John always laughing about
this and that so I tell you that to tell
you about six or seven months ago not
very long ago um I was meeting with a
therapist and she asked me to make a
fist and put it in my chest and say the
words I love this guy
and dude I couldn't do
it at first it was funny I was like ah
stupid and she goes do it and I was like
no come
on now this is somebody who I have told
things I've never told anyone on planet
Earth
ever and she said I'm going to sit here
and wait and so I put my hand in my
chest and I smiled but it wasn't a happy
smile it was I'm smiling so hard to keep
from sobbing I can't say those words
and she said that's where you're going
to start she said as cheesy as this
sounds you're going to look in the
mirror and start practicing saying the
words I love this guy and that's where I
started okay so that's number one it's
got to be something that you practice
and I know it sounds insane but you got
to practice it Okay so that's your
homework assignment even if you have to
fake it act like you're a theater major
and you're doing a performance that's
fine underneath that performative like
just saying the words I love this guy
um you said something really important
that I want you to hang on to you said
voices all say alarms but there's
something really remarkable about the
human mind in that when it sounds the
alarms or it starts speaking up stories
and voices in our heads and it's trying
to get us away from something it's
scared of like a bunch of kids calling
you
Fatso or a bunch of uh teachers telling
you that your grades aren't good enough
or a mom and dad saying don't say that
or you're going to make your dad mad and
or dude don't do that again young man
because your mom gets really pissed off
when you do that and you learn at seven
years old that it's your job to make
sure Mom and Dad are
okay when that
happens um and you avoid those
situations your body wins because it
stayed alive it avoided them and what
does it do it reinforces those voices it
makes the alarms louder and louder and
louder and so in your case the only way
through this is through
it on a foundation of a bunch of little
bitty
winds so give me an example of something
you don't like about
you what is something that you feel is
unlovable uh first thing that that comes
to mind I've just struggle with my whole
life is definitely my body okay my
we against what
standard uh I guess just you know seeing
seeing other people even just like
normal people on the street not even
just like movie stars or something just
I know like man they look good in those
clothes and look pretty cool and I wish
I could and I I don't I couldn't I
wouldn't I don't I couldn't I wouldn't
aren't true statements
so what is are you
overweight I am okay how much
so um maybe 30 pounds or so and I so
after high school I I worked real hard
um you know lost like 60 pounds and now
was back at a a healthy weight and just
since you know over the past 10 years or
so it's just been ticking back up yeah
so let's go with uh yeah that makes
sense cuz my guess is right after high
school you worked out really hard
because you hated that you didn't look
good yeah and you went to the gym every
day to to show because you hated your
body yeah and that is simply not
sustainable my friend Sal the Stefano
has uh he told me that in a private
conversation and the reason I ask up
against what standard is because I've
struggled with body dysmorphia my whole
life and
um I'm comparing myself to whatever the
next standard is whatever line I cross
like oh I look good now I'm always on to
well it's not Brad Pit you know what I
mean it's like as soon as you pass Brad
Pit it's like well I'm not that model
and for you it's not 100 PB that's not
60 lbs well I'm 30
lbs and when you play that game it the
line will always move my promise to you
is if you lost 40 pounds tomorrow
morning and you woke up with a sixpack
ABS you the line would move on you
because you hadn't dealt with the
underlying thing until you can get to a
place where you say I love Easton so I'm
going to take care of
Easton I love myself enough to go give
myself an hour every morning of walking
I love myself enough I I'm just going to
pass on the
donuts do you see how different that is
that's a lifetime that's
sustainable yeah that's how parents work
12 hours a day seven days a week because
they love their kids it's for something
it's not against something so um so
you're overweight and with that comes
all the shame of I should be working out
I should be not eating this I look
terrible and then your wife goes and
cheats on you and it just confirms every
one of those gnarly stories you've been
telling yourself for years right yep
tell me how that
went uh it was it was interesting she I
didn't like Discover it or anything she
uh she had the courage to tell me um and
uh luckily we're both big fans of your
shows and so um I'd heard you know know
a bunch of episodes about people talking
about you know being cheaters and kind
of What It's Like on that side and so
worked real hard to have love and
patience and Grace for her and um she
really appreciated that and so um I
think I started looking at too she made
a decision and she made mistakes um but
it wasn't uh I guess wasn't by herself I
I kind of played a role in creating a an
environment that maybe made those
mistakes easier to make uh I was I was
working too much and uh even when I
wasn't at work I was I was at work in my
head
um so there was a there was a lot of
guilt there and so that paired
with uh the alarms of the voice is
telling me oh yeah of course she did
because you're not
worth you're not worth
laughing sorry no you're good
man it was
easier to to say I forgive you because
it it was just me like it didn't matter
if I was hurt did you ever get
enraged a a couple times not for long
hold on hold on you need to spend some
time being really really
angry let me be super clear you did not
deserve to be cheated on
man I don't care how overweight you are
I don't care how much you work to
provide for your wife and your
family I don't care how much of an
addict you are to
busyness you didn't deserve to be
cheated on and I'm all dude I'm all
about Grace and forgiveness and let's
figure it out I've been married 21 years
man I am a only here because my wife is
somebody who believes in Grace and
forgiveness and let's try again let's
try
again but you didn't deserve this man
nobody deserves to have their soul
ripped out like
that my fear for you
is you went yeah that makes sense I can
see that cuz I'm such a piece of
crap and that's not
true it's almost as though the person
most invested in taking care of you and
defending you
is just kind of giving up on you and
that's
you what's the origin story of that who
told you you weren't worth fighting
for I guess I just been hearing it not
you know not in those exact words but
most of my life if you know kids at
school weren't terrible they were kids
but uh growing up you keep blowing it
off listen brother my closest friends on
the
planet my bestest bestest friends for
years 40e plus friendships used to
tackle me when we were in grade school
and they would have a little sticks and
pine needles and they would poke on all
my zits cuz I had bad
acne and to this day I struggle with
that and dude we were kids they were my
friends we were playing I made fun of
them cuz they were little they made fun
of me cuz I was humongous I made fun of
them because of X they made fun of me CU
I had zits and to this day so you can't
tell me like ah they're just kids that
stuff still hurts and it stays with you
forever
right yeah until you finally are honest
with yourself about how much you were
hurt you're going to continue having to
build these little duct tape Bridges
these duct tape lily pads for you to
walk over the swamp that is your life
I think it would be good for you to
spend some time being honest my mom said
this and that sucked she shouldn't have
said that my dad used to say this and
this and he would hit me here and do
this that was the
worst and my mom treated my dad so bad
or my dad spent all you have to be
honest those kids said these things man
and they are still in
there
can you do that I feel like I'm getting
worked up in your behalf I care about
you feeling bad I think more than you do
I think so have you have you heard of
the Learned helplessness experiment they
did with the
dogs yeah yeah actually that's
you for those of you who don't know what
I'm talking about there's an experiment
done where they had um I'm going to
butcher it but they had a they put dogs
in a cage and the floor was delivered
electric shocks and in short order if
there was no way for the dogs to get out
the dogs just sat there and took it even
when they provided a way for the dogs to
get out and move to another part of that
cage where um there was no electric
shocks the dogs just sat in it they just
sat in it they they just got shocked and
shocked and shocked the other part of
the experiment was when they would turn
it on and they would have other they it
would be intermittent the dogs learned
learned all right I can get out of this
I can get out of this I'm going to keep
fighting I can keep
moving and you just learned to sit there
and take electric shocks
brother so let me flip this whole thing
around what is something that you do
better than anybody else and don't say
nothing because that's not
true I I am a phenomenal budgeter okay
tell that
incredible that tells me that you're a
planner and you're disciplined and
you're
consistent about the few things in life
you can actually
control what else are you great
at um are you good at your
job
uh I I don't know people tell me I am I
don't see is everyone just conspiring to
lie lie to you they all send emails to
each other like oh God here comes Ean
Lista tell him he's great
again I but that's I know that's just
what I I hear in my head too that I know
that's insane but okay so I believe it
um I don't I don't think you believe it
I think it protects
you
and you and I could sit here for a long
time and probably go back to some places
where the things you were good at maybe
you're good in choir maybe you're good
at math those were the things that kids
made fun of you about I happen to be
good at football and good at sprinting
and so those were things everyone high
five and guitar those are things that
high-fived me people high-fived my
little brother was a Sant at the cello
which is something that's easy to poke
at maybe you were great at stuff that
people poked at whatever it happens to
be I think you actually believe your
co-workers I am pretty good at this CU
you wouldn't stay 20 hours a day because
that's where you're getting your uh your
affirmation
from but I think you stay bubble wrapped
in this I got to tell myself it's not
that good because I think something
bad's going to happen if I finally lean
into this thing that I'm good at then
it's going to come crashing down they're
going to make fun of
me and that's where I want you to begin
to seek a some little wins
have you ever you've listened to the
show a lot have you kept a journal that
says five things I'm grateful
for not recently I used to I want you to
start a new
journal and it's five things I love
about Easton every
day and okay I want you to tell your
wife she listens to the show too yep
cool her job is to write down three to
five things that she loves about you and
read them to you every
day listen you're going to have to feel
somebody love
you and that feeling scares you to death
doesn't
it yes sir okay that's the only path
forward the Nerds call it vulnerability
I call it just being a
human you are going to have to practice
learning to hear somebody body when they
say you did you did a good job I love
you I'm sorry and you go I deserved it
no no no I accept your apology because
you hurt me bad bad
bad and then how serious serious are you
about changing
um reimagining an approach to your to
your physical um
well-being I'm I'm serious I don't want
it so bad okay
I want you to do a few things
okay sir number one I just got back from
um San Jose um spending some time with
some of the greatest guys on the planet
the mine pump guys I want you to make
that podcast a regular listen
Okay okay they are four guys from the
fitness and health industry that are
changing the conversation because the
the traditional meat head approach is
not working
second did my voice just crack I'm going
through puberty here second um I want
you to um hang on the line and Jenna's
going to hook you up we're going to give
you any of their workout programs that
you
want thank you they're high dollar
workout programs you can have any of
them you want and I want you to treat
them so much like a budget you budget
because it keeps you safe you budget
because you want to make sure the 70y
old you has
food I want you to approach working out
not as this is what this fat deserves
that's so
bad such a wrong approach I want you to
approach it I want to be able to run and
be silly with my grandkids when I'm 70
I'm gonna start putting money in the
account
now I just I deserve to feel good when I
wake up not
G right I deserve to feel good and it's
a weird way it's chicken or the egg man
do you start the affirmations and start
exercising or you start exercising and
start feeling Worthy have the
affirmations do it all at the same time
I don't
care the second is I'm or the third is
I'm going to hook you up with my buddy
Dr Lane Norton who's another incredible
resource um for nutrition I'm going to
hook you up with a one year of his
carbon app okay and by the way I've got
no affiliation to mine pump guys I don't
make a penny off those guys I don't make
a penny from Lane stuff okay I pay for
his protein I pay out of my own pocket
for it I won't even let him give it to
me for
free um
but I use a carbon app this morning I
want you to use it and it's a good way
to track nutrition and just to help you
be accountable just like you track your
expenses okay okay I'm gonna give those
are two of the best tools out in the
industry right
now the final thing I'm going to tell
you is you have to um write letters to
the five-year-old you to the 10-year-old
you to the 15-year-old
you
probably two to three to four pages and
I want you to be honest about what you
went through if you have to stop and
weep great but I want you to be honest
about what you went through I want you
to be honest about was said to you and
how hard it was and maybe in your
30-year-old State you're like that
wasn't that big of a deal but it was to
you back
then so Own It choose reality in that
moment Own It Own It Own It Own It own
it and as you begin begin to stand a
little taller
don't be surprised if you find yourself
super angry that your wife cheated on
you you should be that doesn't mean you
go backwards but that does mean you have
to feel all the emotions related to
infidelity they're hard and they Ripple
through your life for a long
time you don't have to believe it in
this moment in the shadows that's cool
but we're over here in the
light and I don't lie on this show
you're worth being well and you're worth
being loved my brother
thank you for the call thank you for the
call it starts today I'm going to see
you in a
month and I want you to be down the
road I'll be waiting for
you